hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
terms that you're going to do here the
Stoics using continually is freedom or a
little theory in Greek and epictetus is
going to clarify for us in a very long
chapter and before the nature of genuine
freedom as opposed to what we might call
you know mistaken understandings of
freedom understanding is not only in a
cognitive sense but also in a practical
and effective sense to determining how
people feel what they do not just what
they think about it and the Stoics have
maintained then only in a good man or a
good person rather is free that it's
impossible for a bad person a person who
is mistaken a person who doesn't have
their their Pro erases their faculty of
choice in accordance with nature it's
impossible for them to be genuinely free
even though they may think themselves
temporarily to be free and other people
may look at them as being free and
perhaps even envied their position so
the key question that we want to ask
ourselves then is what actually makes a
person free and Co relatively what makes
a person
that may be a term that we we think of
in our own time is being outmoded
but what Epictetus means is somebody who
is being compelled somebody who is
hindered somebody who is restricted
somebody who is determined by somebody
or something else other than themselves
and so the term slave could apply to
many people in our own time even though
slavery as an institution was thankfully
long ago abolished in the majority of
the world so
Epictetus is going to stress to us
first of all slavery and freedom and
remember he's writing this in the middle
of a slave Society slavery and freedom
in any real sense don't map on to they
don't match up with the social or legal
arrangements for designations so it's
quite possible for somebody to be free
and I'll give you a few examples of that
straight from this text of the moment to
be free and they have that legal status
of a free person and it still be a slave
it's quite impossible for somebody to be
a slave even to be in quite bad
circumstances and yet be a free person
so whatever what are some of the ways in
which he talks about this he says if
some man has been counseled twice the
council is a very very important title
here's this he will forgive you if you
can but you are a wise man this does not
apply to you but if you tell them the
truth in point of being a slave you're
not one whit better than those who have
been traced soul those have been sold to
several different owners what else can
you expect but him to respond family
he'll say how am i asleep
my father was freed my mother was free
no one has a deed of sale for me more
than that I am a member of the Senate
and a friend of Caesar night then
Council and I own many slaves so
epictetus would say look
the problem is now that your somebody
has a deed of ownership for you or that
your designate this as a slave and you
may in fact legally own many people that
are called slaves but you made yourself
be a slave because of the way that you
live your life because of the habits
that you have because of the judgments
that you possess an act upon regarding
what's good and what's bad a little bit
later he has a wonderful passage where
he talks as well about about this sort
of thing and he says here we go
wealth does not make a person their own
master nor does a counsel ship nor
profits nor a kingdom but something else
has to be found so what is that other
thing what can actually make us free if
it's not going to be identified with
legal or social arrangements we need to
think about this in a philosophical way
and he says all sorts of manners there
are all sorts of matters to which the
free can actually be slaves what are
some examples of this the very things
that we think are going to make us free
can sometimes enslave us so he has it as
an example pursuing wealth to pursue
wealth is to pursue something that is by
its very nature rather fickle and
requires a lot of commitments and a lot
of choices to you know do things that
are probably not going to be
particularly really good for our our
Faculty of choice you have to cut
corners you have to be willing to engage
with other people in many ways that may
be a little bit unsavory if we place our
good
in something that is not the genuine
good for human beings which is partly
freedom then we become slaves to the
object that we are devoting ourself to a
little bit earlier he has some great
examples of this he he says yeah doesn't
it strike you as having to do with being
a slave for a man to do something
against his will
under compulsion so you know if you have
to pursue wealth by doing things that
place you under compulsion that go
against you know what you think is right
or what you think is dignified then you
are a slave you are a slave not only to
the wealth but also to the people who
control it he says who didn't put me
under compulsion as the big boss guy now
except for coming except for Caesar the
Lord of all then ever you have admitted
yourself that you have a master let it
not comfort you that it is as you say
the common master of all member realize
you are a slave in a great house doesn't
matter how high up we get into social
hierarchy if we are behaving in a
slavish way we are slaves to somebody or
to something and it doesn't matter
whether they happen to have a lot more
power and whether we can look down upon
others we're still a slave so he says
let the leave Caesar out of account if
you please for the present but answer me
this were you never in love with anyone
a pretty girl a slave a frayed person
what that has had to do with being
either slave or free were you never
commanded by your sweetheart to do
something you didn't wish to do didn't
you cozen your pet slave do you never
kiss their feet
you know if someone should compel you to
kiss the feet of Caesar you regard this
is as insolence and tyranny but when
your lover demands this of you and even
though you don't really want to do it
you do it you're a slave you place
yourself
there's somebody else's power by
desiring something that they in fact
have power over and you dealt something
that they can give you or not give you
if they choose so he says what else then
it slavery did you never go out at night
where you didn't want to go
did you never spend more than you wanted
to spend that's an interesting idea
do we give in to social pressure and
abandon our budgets our plans that is in
a certain respect to be a slave these as
well if you're ashamed to admit such
things about yourself
observe what Joe Simon teased us says it
does a man who had served him so many
campaigns first he went out at night
when Gaeta hasn't the courage to go
abroad because the latter had been
compelled thing to do so he would have
gone up crying a lot on but whaling is
bitter slavery and then what does this
guy say to him a cheap little wench has
made it be a perfect slave of me though
never a one among all my phone men might
and epictetus says Wow how the mighty
have fallen to be a slave of a cheap
wench why do you call yourself free
Epictetus is basically saying to us we
need to think about what it is that we
tell ourselves we can't do without what
is it then we allow to have control over
us and it's not just a matter of those
things having control over us it's also
a matter of the people who control those
things thereby also having control over
us as well whether they realize it or
not
there are many different possible ways
we can go wrong with this so what's the
opposite what does it mean then to be
actually free at one point he talks
about being free it means being
independent having self-governance and
not in everything but in what it is
actually one's up one's Faculty of
choice how one thinks about things how
one feels about things how one chooses
that is something that does lie in our
pub
if we don't want to be slaves to fear we
don't have to be slaves to fear if we
don't want to be slaves to sexual desire
or some sort of addiction or you know
social pressure those are things that
epic tedious seven-line within the scope
of our power may be very difficult to go
against them but not impossible
he also says living as one wills free
and compulsion this is in the very
beginning he says what does it mean to
be free he is free who live as as he
wills who is subject neither the
compulsion or hindrance or force whose
choices are unhampered whose desires
attain their end whose aversions do not
fall into what they would avoid another
thing that he points out to us is very
important it's not just being able to do
what we what we desire because we've
managed to control our desires and make
them rational it's also being in the
truth not being in a state of error to
be in a state of error it is to be in a
state of slavery that's part of what
he's connecting up there so he says
being in truth acting rightly possessing
the good a little bit later he says who
was just to live in error no one who
wishes to live deceived impetuous unjust
unrestrained peevish abject no one and
here we come again to this consumption
that know there is no bad person who
actually lives as they want to and
accordingly no bad person is free only
the good can actually be free he goes on
who was just to live in grief fear Envy
pity desiring things and failing to get
them avoiding things and falling into
them nobody do we find then any bad
people who are actually free from grief
or fear not falling and what they would
avoid not failing to achieve what they
desire no that's a way of becoming a
slave now he also said something very
interesting about halfway through the
chapter we
many people who are what He is calling
slaves imagine to themselves that if
they just change their condition a
little bit better that they will then
become free so freedom is always over
the horizon rather than inside of them
where they could actually realize and so
those that are displacing it to
externals how does this actually work
skipping over their discussion of the
animals he says it's a slave's prayer
the person who actually is legally
enslaved that he be set free immediately
why do you think it's because he's eager
to pay his money to the men who collect
the five percent tax no it's because he
fancies that up until now he's hampered
and uncomfortable because he has not
obtained his freedom from slavery and
then this could apply in so many other
things you know when I when I was in the
Army we heard obviously when I get back
to the world when I take up my real life
but you're living the real life right
now students say oh what I'm done with
school people say I when I get to retire
the problem is if we're slaves to things
now simply changing our social condition
or our financial condition is not
actually going to alter that he says the
slave says if I'm set free immediately
all its happiness I shall pay no
attention to anybody I talked to
everybody isn't equal and one in the
same station of life I go as I please I
come where it pleases them where I
please and then he's emancipated and
after that he's got no place to go and
eat he looks for someone to flatter
someone's house at which to dine
he starts earning a living by sordid
ways and so endure his dreadful things
he gets a manger at which to eat and
he's fallen into a slavery more extreme
than the rest he starts to say man it
was pretty good at being a slave at
least then I didn't have to fend for
myself as he says
let's see things go well for you if he
grows rich being able Aryan he's
following it along with some girl on
mr. Gulen laments and yearns for slavery
again he goes on further and further
when he gets the things that he wants he
doesn't turn out to be happy
he says if I served in a campaign on
adventure right I'll get honored I'm rid
of all my troubles he serves in a
campaign he submits to all of it
jailbird suffers but nonetheless he
demands a second campaign and a third
after that it has the very coalified in
the honor and becomes a senator then he
becomes a slave as it he enters the
Senate and he arrives hers and the
handsomest and sleekest slavery the
slave constantly imagines that if he can
just alter his condition he is going to
be better off but a penis would say you
want genuine freedom you have to attend
to the real conditions for it you have
to free yourself of these desires for
things that you don't have control over
and aversions to things that you don't
have control over either and focus upon
the things that you actually do we have
control over and how to improve your
your Faculty of choice your character so
that is the nature of genuine freedom as
opposed to slavery for epictetus